please welcome leslie jordan
and look at youtube you look so good i
love you
oh you look so good to look v you look
very proper and a little
scarf ascotti well i dressed
[Laughter]
i'm just so excited to be speaking with
you here today i'm such a fan of yours
and
especially what you've done and
accomplished in 2020 with putting
yourself out there on social media
it's just been such a bright light for
everyone well it wasn't really planned
it just kind of happened i was
stuck in tennessee with my mom for the
lockdown and
i started doing instagrams to pass the
time i did two a day for 80 days and i
just
without even thinking it through i
didn't go anywhere near politics i
didn't go anywhere near religion
i just wanted to give people you know a
place to go where they could just laugh
you know people come up to me in grocery
stores and say
oh mr jordan i was stuck at home i got
three kids my husband
i would come to you once a day just for
a good laugh and i would look forward to
you know you realize how important just
comedy is
especially now
completely agree you are a national
treasure and you have made people and
that authenticity of
putting it out there with those
brilliant intentions is probably why it
connected so much with everybody
so thank you yeah in 2012 now you're
welcome
it was so hard leslie and every day i i
know myself and
millions of other people would go to
your ig just to
feel better so thank you for what you
gave us thank you honey
that's so sweet leslie would you be kind
enough to join us in some headlines at
the news desk
absolutely oh good okay ross take it
away okay let's you got to talk
so many people are conducting radical
hair experiments this year because
people growing
out in quarantine men's health says if
you've ever
mold a mullet the time is now and celebs
are showing off their party tales from
miley cyrus to billy eilish and of
course country star morgan wallin
rocks a mullet and stylists say it is
now the prime
time for a mullet moment because people
have been growing their hair out so you
can trim
trim the sides a mullet doesn't work for
everybody i um
i'm pretty passionate that it it's you
know business in the front and
poor life choices in the back but
this is what i would look like with a
mullet uh drew
i have to say sort of hot anyone else
turn um ross
i'm in you're in yeah well let's see
what you would look like in a moment
hey drew i'm out
leslie we got you too oh
you look sweet are you a mullet man
leslie
no no not at all i remember the very
first mullet i saw was probably
jane fonda believe it or not yeah that
movie called
clute but see back then we called it the
shag i think
but it was a molly yeah the shag
but uh no i never had that i did you
know i'm
i was in 1969 i was 14 so all i wanted
out of life to be
was to be a hippie and i had all this
hair and my hair was kind of red
big i looked like a little tr rock and
roll
troll doll
this big one by the way if you can get
us a picture of that leslie we would be
real oh well i bet you looked so good
okay well sticking with style news let's
turn to the latest
in furry fashion in style reports that
you can now buy
ugg boots for your dog that's right put
a pug
in an ugg these booties come in a
classic
tan and in a black with green trim
leslie do you have a little doggie would
you put them in
uggs i don't have a doggie and i don't
get uggs
don't your feet sway it there was pam i
was running on the beach
i thought i bet her feet
[Laughter]
i have three dogs and there's you know
we live in palm springs and coming here
to new york these dogs
their feet are cold so i i want to rush
order
don't take don't pause
don't delay you know what's also really
helpful about these
uggs is that um in east coast places
um not something i knew growing up in
california they salt
the roads and that salt actually
burns the uh dog's paws it's really
toxic for them it burns right through
the skin
so you'll see a dog so the ugg boots are
really smart for that
and then robin she is really heavy into
design and was like you know what i have
lighter carpets and i put my dogs in
them so they don't ruin them when we
take them outside
[Music]
well there you go so don't burn your dog
and keep your carpets clean leslie and
you would look cute with a little dog i
gotta say
oh i've had dogs over the years i've
always had big dogs i love
labs but then again i went through a
long jack russell terrier phase
i had little earl for 18 years i had a
little jack russell
he was a criminal honey how to rap sheep
long as your arm
i couldn't i never even hyper trained
him
his dog is a criminal i love it well
you have stolen our hearts leslie jordan
for many years
and you really propped us up in the year
we needed it most thank you for joining
well you both are just precious and i
wish you the best with this
job well thank you leslie
[Music]
you